[Music]
these trucks are designed to run on
electricity
not gas and some investors are betting
that they're the future
the pressure is mounting for one company
in particular nikola
nikola nikola shares for the electric
and hydrogen vehicle startup
have seen big swings this year despite
the company having yet to sell a single
truck
in september shares rose 11 in a single
day
after the company struck a deal with
general motors and then
crashed in response to a short seller's
allegations of fraud
and an investigation into whether the
company had misrepresented its progress
to investors founder trevor milton
stepped down as following the
allegations
the buzzer on nikola represents a larger
trend in the market
investors and big automakers looking for
a piece of eevee startups in a quest
to find the next tesla the nikola story
is a fear of missing out story
is nicola the next tesla is nikola the
the gamble that i need to make today
that i
either didn't make before or want to
make again
[Music]
to understand you have to look back to
2010 when tesla motors was just taking
hold in the auto world
for a long time tesla was seen as this
complete
anomaly to a pretty consistent story
which was investors did not like
electric cars
and the reason they didn't like electric
cars is because they lose money
but in 2010 tesla announced a
partnership with toyota
in return for an auto factory in fremont
california toyota would receive a 50
million dollar stake in the electric
vehicle startup
a month later tesla went public and its
stock surged
tesla started to make money they started
to show
some degree of market share penetration
and probably most importantly they
proved that they know how to build cars
[Music]
in march 2016 toyota's 2.3 million tesla
shares were
valued at 480 million dollars and by the
end of the year
the company cashed out the relationship
between toyota and tesla was one of
necessity in the beginning toyota had
something to gain
tesla had something to gain it was a
factory and it was technology
toyota minimized the potential
of tesla's technology and tesla ran away
with the
factory and used it to become a
significant player in the luxury car
market
now other automotive heavyweights want
to find the next tesla
and hold on to it with the hopes of
cashing in
introducing the most advanced semi truck
the world has ever seen
some are betting on nikola named after
the famous engineer
and physicist nikola tesla the
connection to rival car company tesla
is no coincidence by 2016 tesla was
already a household name
and nikola took the opportunity to
capitalize on its popularity
when the company announced its first
vehicles that year it came with big
promises
it's my pleasure to introduce the nikola
one to the world
just months later tesla also made a
wager that big rig ev trucks would be a
hit
we are guaranteeing that this truck will
not break down
for a million miles
[Applause]
following the reveal investors piled in
to tesla stock
both companies were promising to wean
the trucking industry off diesel
but using different approaches tesla
committed to all electric vehicles
while nikola said that hydrogen fuel
cell technology in addition to electric
would better power the trucks the
ability to outperform a diesel in every
category not only that but 100 zero
emission
musk hasn't always shared the same views
about hydrogen
if you're going to pick an energy
storage mechanism hydrogen is incredibly
dumb one to pick
while hydrogen fuel has captivated
public interest for years
companies have struggled to bring the
technology to scale
it's very expensive and it's also very
difficult
to get a fueling infrastructure when you
think about the big mac
truck they're still running on diesel
right now or they're still
using a combination of power trains
engines and stuff to get down the road
there aren't charging stations all over
america
you know just waiting for a semi truck
to come in and plug in
for years nicola has assured investors
that it had plans for a network of
hydrogen fueling stations
as well as new battery technology but so
far
these promises remain unfulfilled and
some skeptics are wary of nikola's
ability to follow through
they have investors that stand behind
them they have a ton of engineers that
work for them they have a lot of capital
and they have customers that believe in
them but the one thing they don't have
is a
provable product on the road right now
we're almost entirely in the hype
phase of electric semi trucks
despite this investors have still piled
on and companies have placed
large orders for trucks that have yet to
be made in 2018
anheuser-busch placed an order for 800
of nikola's hydrogen electric trucks
and to demonstrate the technology nikola
completed what it claims
was the world's first zero-emission beer
delivery a year later
near anheuser-busch's headquarters in st
louis the trucks were slated for
delivery in 2020
but the company later pushed that
deadline
there are investors who put an awful lot
of money we're talking
hundreds of millions of dollars into
this company saying that they have seen
the technology and that they are true
believers
and these are automotive experts but as
we sit here
in 2020 they have not earned
a single dollar of revenue doing these
plans
so that's why there's big skepticism
still in june 2020
the company went public through a
reverse merger which is when a public
shell company invests money in a private
company
and combines with it nikola's market
share
briefly surged past ford and though the
company has gained a lot of attention
it's not the only electric truck maker
on the scene there's byd
there's volvo there's daimler there's
navistar
and the list goes on and on with
nikola's stock riding high
in august it released an earnings report
that it had lost 86 million dollars
while pulling in essentially no revenue
and just a week later
the company bagged another deal shares
of nikola surging today the company
inking a deal with waste management
giant republic services
to provide 2 500 electric garbage trucks
shortly after the company announced the
partnership with gm
nikola forming a strategic partnership
with general motors this morning nicola
badger will be
engineered and manufactured by gm as a
result
gm will get an 11 stake in nikola and a
seat on its board
gm will also be supplying its own
battery and hydrogen fuel cell
technology
we realize we shared a common vision of
the world of creating an all-electric
feature
amid a rush of positive press niklas
shares soared
companies like general motors and ford
motor company are very eager to find
partnerships that they can rely on and
it shows you
they do not want to deal with the
downside of losing influence with a
company
that could be a big deal still skeptics
are making bets that the company will
fail
just days after the partnership with gm
was announced a short seller released
a report accusing nikola a fraud and
later
news surfaced that federal prosecutors
were probing allegations that nikola
misrepresented progress
made in developing its technology nicola
denies allegations of fraud
and general motors says they will
continue to work with nikola to engineer
and build the nikola badger
and that teaming with nicola is just one
part of its overall
ev strategy so
is nicola the next tesla for some
investors the risk of partnering with an
eevee startup
is worth the potential reward